[Music]
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake and
really excited to be talking about
liquid democracy we have david ernst sai
ray joining us on the show hello guys
great thanks so much for coming on
really appreciate it I'm super super
excited for this episode for those who
don't know David Aaronson sorry are
building liquid democracy which is a
21st century rethinking of democratic
representation and you can find the
links in the bio below liquid dot US as
well as their YouTube channel liquid
future org as well as David's page
liquid David calm the candidates page
liquid candidates calm in their Twitter
profile as well guys let's start things
off with one of our favorite questions
to ask our guests what are your thoughts
on the direction of our world yeah
overall there's a lot to be optimistic
about and there are some things that are
pretty concerning there's amazing
breakthroughs happening all the time but
at the same time there's tension
happening there's turmoil all around the
world people are losing faith and
governments and leaders and
representation and as long as we have
open and honest conversations I think
there's there's a lot of hope to get
things in a really positive direction
but current status quo trends leave a
lot of people somewhat concerned yeah
and and just to add on to that there are
definitely a lot of reasons to be
concerned about the future of the world
and politics and democracy and
everything else and I think for a lot of
good reasons people often feel
frustrated about the direction that our
institutions are going in but there are
debt it's important to keep in mind
there you know not just us but lots of
people around the world who are looking
to explore innovative and creative
solutions to solving lots of the big
problems that our generation is facing
and so overall I'm optimistic about the
future and then what with in your
journeys led you guys to be so
interested
with liquid democracy go first
yeah sure so actually I've only been
working on liquid democracy and with
with David on liquid us for a few months
before that I was actually living in
South Korea where I was a Korean
government scholarship research fellow
and my area of expertise was in North
Korea and North Korea is a name a
democratic country but in practice it's
the exact opposite of that it's a
totalitarian despotic sort of
authoritarian regime people have no
freedom of movement no human rights no
representation in their government and
so I think probably by studying a case
that's so starkly contrasts with the
kind of system that we have in America
and the kind of system that we want to
improve upon and build out sort of real
democracy made me really curious about
ways that we could achieve that seeing a
place in the world where democracy
didn't exist made me realize how
important it was and so I remember one
time when I was just back in America on
vacation from school I was hanging out
with David and he pitched me on this
idea called liquid democracy and I found
it to be really inspiring and powerful
and that's what led me to where we are
today yeah yeah just just a sneak about
North Korea I saw a headline he was
yesterday that one of Kim jong-un's top
associates was just killed by firing
squad
because he the way a diplomatic summit
with Trump went they weren't happy with
it and so there's executed them just
like yesterday mm-hmm
so that's is a reality in one part of
the world and hopefully we can move in
the opposite extreme yeah to fill out my
personalized there did you want to add
no go for it develop my personal answer
I I grew up around politics a lot talked
about it around the dinner table all the
time I was always personally really
frustrated by the partisanship by the
way it was like so tribal and so
team-based it's like our team is it's
flawless and the other
is evil can never be trusted corrupt all
these say and both sides were saying
this exact same story so that was a
little there's some cognitive dissonance
going on there so I was always confused
and then I was doing a few projects to
try to help what I saw I was hoping a
situation especially in 2016
trying to get people to understand what
was happening and one thing led to
another and we were realizing what is
now possible with technology and working
with friends we saw what other people
were doing around the world and that's
when we were really deeply introduced to
these ideas of liquid democracy and the
concept has been out there since like
2000 or so it's it goes back a while but
there wasn't always easy to use reliable
free interface technology to actually
make it a reality and that's something
that my personal background that I've
done a number of times and so I saw an
opportunity to help push the ball
forward and push and so just talking
about I just share this this idea with
friends like with psy and with other
people and when we go into depth with it
when they'd have an open conversation
they'd be like oh my god that's
incredible you have to please do this
you have to work on this that sounds
amazing so it was just so contagious and
for about three years now
okay so first is this example of
dichotomy between place in the world
that has absolutely no freedom no human
rights no representation in their
governance versus ones that do and so to
at least have the gratitude to realize
that Wow okay at least we have this and
then there's still a lot to improve on
but at least we have this and how do we
help make it so that other humans in the
world can have human rights okay and
then then we also have this if the
the partisanship that we see today the
tribalism that we see today the biases
and dissonance is that we see today need
to be we need to be mended that the
nuance needs to be explored the love and
compassion towards each other needs to
be explored better to figure out how to
best move forward and then we have new
technologies in place as well that are
enabling things like virtual citizens
blockchain technology is taking a stance
in politics as well
decentralized Ledger's also not be able
to just remove people off the face of
the earth for their land and their money
these types of things so we have a lot
of interesting things that are sort of
brewing in this pot of life of the
future of democracy which is super
exciting and you guys will be explaining
to us kind of like on a liquid side of
things how to be able to how to actually
have your own representation and yeah so
I'm really looking forward to that I
want to hit on something on the way is
let's do a little um lesson on on
history as well so so post independence
post 1776 we explored what was our our
our our Constitution and our own Bill of
Rights and our own way of having a three
branch style of governance and we've had
that sense with amendments we've had
that sense 240 years so to think that
with the exponential technology age at a
population that's hockey-stick that we
should keep things the same as ludicrous
we need to update and so would you speak
on part of the history and and where we
see some of the most pressing updates
totally yeah I mean and even going back
before 1776 the vast majority of humans
that have ever been alive at least since
the Agricultural Revolution for the last
ten thousand years have lived under a
warlord
I've lived over in some sort of
absolutist system with one with one
ruler so even the idea of democracy I
mean you're talking about going back 200
years it's kind of an anomaly on in
human history and self-governance when
they talked about when the American
founders talked about the American idea
it was seen as this like experiment and
so
governance and it was moving away from
the monarchy of the British system and
of course the British system was a
constitutional monarchy so they did have
their parliament with a House of Lords
and house of comments but but really
democracy is a relatively new idea and
most of the countries think by number
less than half the countries in the
world even today claim to be democracies
it's it's been about 20 years since we
hit the 50 percent mark that's still not
very we have a long ways way to go yeah
and it's questionable you know how many
of those are real democracies where
people have feel like they're actually
being representative yeah and how many
of those are just kind of nominal yeah
yeah so then exactly if you're talking
about the the world has changed in so
many ways I mean to imagine that we
would use the transportation technology
of 1776 that's a horse
and and the actual communication of
infrastructure at the time was you write
a letter with a quill you give it to a
person on a horse and they ride for a
week to get your message from New York
City to Philadelphia I mean so that's
one direction versus today you know we
can send a text message instantly we can
stream a video all around the world
nearly instantly so so much of our world
has changed and we see that and just
about every industry except the way that
we collectively address the problems
that we face as a country as States as
regions as cities for the most part it's
really still based on these ideas from
the 18th century which exactly like you
say is something to be grateful for
I mean without a doubt it's it's got us
a long way it's built the roads police
firefighters there's a lot to be proud
of there but at the same time there's so
many signs and so many measurable things
that you can point to where people are
not satisfied and not happy and it
there's a certain trend where it sort of
seems like someone used the phrase a
friend said it seems like democracy is
bursting at the seams right now
and so it's concerning just because
there are Trent this has happened before
we've seen cases there are IMF has done
lots of studies of what happens in
places where people no longer have faith
in democracy and it very quickly turns
into hell on earth I mean it's just
society's collapse and it just gets
really ugly and so I'm of the opinion
and I think a lot of people are of the
opinion that we ought to be able to do a
lot better given what our modern tools
are available to us and and so many
other things
any thoughts are you saying yeah I mean
just really quickly you know as David
said there's a lot of things to like
about the way our founding fathers you
know set things up in the 18th century
separation of powers I think is really
really important I like the fact that
the administrative judicial judiciary
and legislative branches can work in
place checks on each other and make sure
none of them are you know abusing their
power or stepping out of line at the
same time there are a lot of things
there are a lot of ways in which the
world has changed that I think our
founding fathers you know definitely
couldn't have anticipated and so in
order to tackle some of these modern
challenges we have to be innovating and
thinking about creative solutions ways
to do that you know traditionally the
government is not known as being the
like this really quickly evolved being
very adaptable rapidly sort of advancing
institution it's very slow and
bureaucratic and that's challenging and
the really cool thing about liquid
democracy and maybe we'll get to this a
little bit later is that it really helps
solve a lot of the biggest problems that
are political you know environment is
facing today
corruption gerrymandering law lobbying
you know this sort of crisis of
under-representation liquid offers
really really useful solutions to those
problems and so that's why you know
we're working on what we're what we're
working on and so
I didn't unpack them let's let's do um
some of the on the some of the the
slides the the images that we have the
very first one is a congressional job
approval ratings from 2002 to 2009 teen
do you approve of the way Congress is
handling its job yeah yeah so this is a
very simple metric that you can point to
that just suggest that people are not
happy with our government right now and
it's just this base on
Gallup polling every year multiple times
a year they just asked a random sample
of citizens yay nay do you approve of
the job Congress is doing so it's
actually at a high point just after
September 11th and it's just been on a
downward trend for nearly 20 years now
its hovered really around like the 20%
mark if not at some points down as low
as 10% so like 9 out of 10 people for
large amounts of time have said we don't
approve of Congress of our
representation in the government yeah
and that's definitely worth being aware
of yeah
it's a concerning trend and then the
next way for a long time I mean this
isn't one year two years this goes back
decades yeah yeah and to be hovering
around like a 20 percent mark is yeah
it's egregious there's a new updates
have to get deployed yes yes okay and
then the next one Ronnie this one you
found this one it surprised me because
it's really stark this is just gets to
specific criticisms that people make of
politicians and so it's a percentage of
Americans who say most election
officials lose touch with people quickly
don't care what people like me think put
their own interests before the country's
interests are corrupt or just simply
can't be trusted and every single one of
these metrics is over three-quarters
these can't be trusted when it's almost
nine out of ten so I mean that's not -
not to indict the individual people the
way I read this more than anything else
is the system itself is creating these
really perverse incentives yes we're
we're just left with with
leadership that we don't believe in and
that's I mean who wants to live in that
and one of the aspects of this that I
think is now bursting at the seams as
you said earlier is that the amount of
our family values from the kin tribes
that we used to live in just did not
scale and so then all of the self
dealing I'm now telling you a story to
sell you [ __ ] that you don't need
instead of telling you a story for your
fitness inclusive fitness levels yeah
and so that's why we have the
politicians are self dealing rather than
actually representing on like an
inclusive stake holding methodology and
I really do think that some technologies
like boxing could really help with
things like that well it's it's
interesting you bring that up that's a
that's a really fascinating lens to look
at it through so there's one we don't
have a graph up on here but one way to
think about this is just the number of
representatives and the number of people
that they're representing and just think
of that as a ratio of how many
constituents per representative and so
right now there's five hundred members
of Congress that we're looking
nationally and there's 300 million
Americans and so it's about a million to
one
give or take it's 700 something odd
thousand to one you know and that number
is it's absurd when you think about it
one person is supposed to represent the
interests and the political beliefs of
700,000 people and what was it when we
first start exactly that's exactly point
is it wasn't designed to be like this
this was actually so - you're just the
short answers your question is 30,000 it
was 30,000 yeah first starters 30,000 to
one and this was actually meant to be
the very first amendment to the
Constitution before freedom of speech
and freedom of religion and freedom of
assembly and freedom of the press they
the original Congress the very first
Congress in 1789 passed what's called
the congressional apportionment
amendment it's like this little story
that most people have never heard where
they want to write into the Constitution
will add a new member of Congress every
time it gets above originally 30,000 and
then once they got past 200 it was gonna
read
for 40,000 per representative and once
gossip a 300 isn't raised at 50,000 per
representative so what it would mean is
that today we'd have like 8,000 members
of Congress yeah and you just have a
much closer relationship with your
representative you should know them a
lot better know them a lot better and
there's less self-dealing so who would
have scaled Congress to 8,000 members
maybe it would be harder to potentially
pass some of the legislators like yeah
that we want but at the same time there
would be less self-dealing more
inclusive fitness yeah yeah and just add
on to that I mean the one to 30,000
ratio to me it is better than what we
have now but it still doesn't sound very
good I mean like I said I mean I would
love I mean so one of the things we do a
lot when we talk to people about this
idea of look at democracy is we just
asked him a simple question which is do
you know who you're you know local state
and national representatives are and so
just a few days ago we did this event
this really cool political kind of bar
cafe space called manis and David was a
panelist you know running an event about
the future of democracy and he asked
people in the audience this question of
do you know who is representing you in
government and very politically engaged
people right so what percentage would
you say of the audience knew the answer
to that question maybe one in five right
so this is a problem from my perspective
let's talk about that who who in San
Francisco is representing us right now
so in the city level there's a Board of
Supervisors it's 11 supervisors each one
represents a different district so where
we are right now I think we're in
district 6 and on soma
so that's Jane Camp Jane Kim okay yeah
and then yeah you're there yep and then
Gavin Newsome of the entire state yep
okay and then we have Senators and
Representatives also of the state yeah
two senators 50 representatives I don't
know for the whole state Pelosi is the
wine for all of San Francisco Pelosi is
for a million people seven
11,000 right person yeah I mean the
Senators are even more cuz there's 25
million registered Californians so
that's a million yeah for one senator
yeah yeah come on Harrison Feinstein and
so and so but there's an argument made
that they represent the state not the
individual people that's I mean that's
officially what it is cuz every state
they get to no matter the number of
people in this day Wow it's it's a crazy
job and so imagine being that person and
trying to hear from all your
constituents every day no it's
impossible it's impossible you won't
have time to breathe Reese's family be
in nature none of that yeah so there
doesn't need to be a better way yeah
okay I mean I was just gonna add on to
that I love this idea of kind of the
family or the tribal unit and I think
our politicians in a perfect world ought
to be you know we ought to trust them as
much as we can trust our parents or
siblings or our best friends Yeah right
now it feels like we're so disconnected
from them it's like you know first of
all how can one person ever represent a
million people it's just logically
impossible and it's just weird that I'm
represented by this person that I don't
really know I've never met I don't know
that much about them and they don't know
that much about me yes
and so yeah exactly even if you don't
vote for them they're still you're still
stuck with us
things have to change and and just
another thing that I was thinking about
as you guys were chatting is
I remember hearing this statistic that
that people members of Congress spend
something like 70 percent of their time
lobbying you know donors trying to get
money for that for their campaigns to
re-election and they're spending that
much time ain't you know hanging out
with rich people trying to get money how
much time are they really spending
engaging with the population as a whole
or thinking about the best ways to vote
on legislation or actually doing their
job so you know we have a lot of
problems damn yeah we also didn't plan
for that to happen where 70 percent of
the time of the people that represent a
suspending campaign financing yeah
that's such a corrupt well but you have
to do it I mean
you don't fundraise then you lose yeah
it's very simple and so it's not again
it's it's not even that these people are
Devils it's that the system itself has
created these rules that yes can't
compete any other way as is now like to
be said our founding fathers or the
rolling in the grave wondering why we
haven't deployed updates to well there's
that quote from Jefferson like we should
renew the Constitution every generation
every generation yeah yeah that's a
great quote yeah yeah yeah and their
deploy the right updates yeah yeah it
makes sense yeah it's a very interesting
idea I'm not sure if I would want to go
that far because I think there are a lot
of really important and meaningful
valuable ideas in the Constitution to
like freedom of speech totally
and so that's but I think a lot of the
issues that we're facing really have to
do specifically with our legislature and
under representation in this democratic
process and so you know I still want a
constitution I still want a you know a
president and a judiciary but I'm just
really trying to tackle a lot of the
problems surrounding for example
Congress or yes yes okay so let's go to
the third a [ __ ] Ron okay so three
versions of democracy walk a serious
okay so direct democracy a lot it when a
lot of people think about what we have
now they referred to as representative
democracy I think that's a misnomer I
would call it electoral democracy
because it's based on elections so
that's what we see right now we pick
these members of Congress or City
Council members there are
representatives there are elected
representatives and they vote on issues
for us and ancient Athens direct
democracy 1.0 was Oslo ting directly on
the issues ourselves exactly so when
people talk about the birth of democracy
they want to point to the Athenian forum
going back 2,000 years ago and that's
500 people gathering in a space together
voting directly on should we do this
with our shared Treasury should we go to
war here
we make this law and it's there's no
representatives it's you're voting
directly and you still see that today
with referendums ballot initiatives we
do sometimes still take direct votes but
a lot of people think of our governance
options as these this balancing act
between representatives through these
elected leaders and direct where you're
voting on citizen initiatives and bad
initiatives and that's those are two
extremes and now we can do better and
that's what what liquid democracy is all
about mm-hmm and so it combines exactly
it gives you all of the options and so
just to speak to that very quickly so
there are a lot of people there's the
polling on it's something like 50
percent of the population or something
say they want to see or direct democracy
in the US it's very high number
surprisingly high number and Elon Musk
has said a bunch of times when he has
his million person calling on Mars he
thinks it ought to be governed by all
people having an app where they can vote
directly on policy instead of having
elected representatives direct democracy
for all million people it only makes
sense that if something gets drafted in
the legislature and that rather than
having somebody we got to be educated on
the like what do we actually have the
capacity to read and understand what the
actual law that we're voting on is or if
we don't then can we do the
representative I cast it to you because
I trust that you know that you are going
to read it and make a decision that on
behalf of me exactly at the idea of
everyone weighing in on the policy makes
a lot of sense when everyone is in the
same room together
it's it's the most authentic option you
could have it totally plays on the side
you have consent of the governed if
we're gonna make a law that this is
illegal or we're gonna spend our shared
taxpayer dollars on this it makes a lot
of sense that we all would consent to it
well it it just takes a lot of time I
mean it would be crazy to imagine every
single one of us was gonna look through
the ten thousand bills that were
introduced in Congress last year I mean
they took hundreds and hundreds of roll
call votes ten thousand
just in one year yeah just last year
there were ten dozen bills introduced
and a few hundred about 500 of them got
brought to a roll call vote all the
members of Congress and so we all live
busy lives I mean we all have jobs all
families we have school and other
responsibilities and so it would be
moving backward the people that think
that direct democracy we just need more
direct democracy are missing the fact
that that takes an enormous amount of
time and this stuff is really
complicated and you want to get it right
I mean you think about you know Obama
care one of the big pieces major pieces
of legislation arguably a large piece of
legislation passed in the last decade he
was a thousand pages and so expecting
every last person to read a thousand
page bill it's just no way
no of course not and when you had back
in when he had so much time in the
ancient Athenian times that could be
more easy to direct democracy well those
people were actually wealthy the people
voting were all retired aristocrats
mm-hmm so this was their full-time job I
mean this was all they did you know just
also just not yeah selling eight hours
of their day every day for money also
just because then you could spend those
eight hours engaging with your
communities figuring out what you wanted
to do for the future kids etc during
those eight hours yeah yeah so that's
that's what the situation has always
looked like now well we can talk about
the future solution why liquid democracy
offers sometimes dos referred to as
delegative democracy because it's based
on this idea of personal delegations
instead of electing one representative
for a million people you get to actually
pick your own representative and the
mechanism very simply is that each and
every person can vote up or yea or nay
on any item any legislative item and if
you don't vote on it then you're
personally chosen representative gets to
vote on your behalf for you mm-hmm
so you get the best of both worlds you
can always weigh in yourself when you
want and when you're not weighing in
yourself you still have your
representative as a backup for you okay
so there's something that I have to a
timeline to place my vote on and if I've
placed my vote okay great it's locked in
if I haven't and
and the final then the person that I
let's say that Dave is the one that's
casting that's my delegate that I want
to cast a vote that if I haven't cast it
by that time and Dave has my vote gets
added to the one that Dave would be
casting yeah yeah if you want to pull
the demo this is your perfect show so
nice so this is what the current system
looks like with the electoral we'll just
skip right through this but basically
the current system is we have this two
classes we have regular citizens around
the outside here and then we have a few
politicians who are so have so much more
influence than everybody else and it's
just it's this two class system so now
we're gonna switch to and the and it was
all of us on the outside and the person
that's elected to represent us so that's
like the one hundred thousand five
hundred thousand all on the outside and
one person on the inside which used to
only be thirty thousand which is still a
crazy crazy number yeah so this is what
a liquid democratic system can look like
so this is an example of people being
able to weigh in on a single issue so
right now just a few days ago Congress
is voting on should we give funding to
areas that have been experiencing these
disasters like hurricanes this is big
bill being fought in Congress right now
so assume that that's the example we're
working with right now so any one person
like Leah here can say yes I'm in favor
of that or they could say no I'm against
that you can see the tally here Jiujiang
mm-hmm people in favor of people against
and someone else can vote exact same
thing but see now we also have these
arrows what is this cluster that's
happening yeah it was already just pre
set up this is just a sample but the
point is that exact so these arrows show
that delegation okay this person here
says I'm in favorite all these people
who have said ahead of time hey I trust
Daisy they're gonna inherit they're
gonna adopt and copy that exact same
vote
yeah okay this lets you see what a
liquid democratic system actually
looks like in practice same thing this
the breezin there in the center is
because a lot of people trust that
position there they're elevating them
they're empowering them as a leader for
but then can Julian pass the vote from
Julian like if 5 1 2 3 4 5 people have
passed their vote to Julian for yay but
then Colton says no yeah exactly so so
let's say Colton here they're very
influential they're against the thing
but actually is like wait I actually am
in favorite thing they can just override
and take it back in real time at any
time you always represent yourself you
can always weigh and you're always in
control
so if Ashley's passing the vote to
Colton that in Colton votes no but
everyone with Ashley was voting okay
exactly
I was delegating to Ashley okay yeah
there's a III gave a little bit of a
misleading description I I always say
that it's if you were not voting your
vote is getting passed to the person but
a simpler way to think are a more
accurate way to think about it is
actually that Quinn here didn't vote and
so when Ashley voted Quinn says look up
how Ashley voted and just copy the same
position yeah okay okay so it's the vote
never actually left from Quinn position
yeah I already said I liked that person
I trust that question for the most part
I agree that person however they did it
I want to copy the same that's great so
it's not like Ashley's getting 40,000
votes it's a yeah
it's more that Quinn's copying Ashley's
one vote and if 30,000 people believe in
at the way the Ashley's voting then the
vote will be copied okay so you still
always stay in control you can always
speak yourself you can always and if you
and if you pick someone and you realize
wait a second I actually don't trust
this for and they've made all these
promises and then they didn't keep them
or you know this happens all the time of
course you can just change it in real
time change over time and then can can
actually if I'm dedicating my vote to
actually can actually then pass the vote
along to Colton yeah yeah so only if
Ashley is public is saying I publicly
believe in Colton Oh
so there's a separate so there's a
separate question to be asked here about
as your VOC public or private okay and
so the way we've designed it with liquid
us and other people have different
opinions about this but the way we've
designed is you always can choose do you
want to be public or private okay
whenever you make a private boat it
doesn't get passed down to anybody
so you're just voting for yourself as
one person okay whenever you make a
public vote then it gets passed down to
everybody and so that's your question
because you have multiple degrees
multiple levels as long as it's public
because everyone needs to be able to see
what you know where the vote is coming
from who's being trusted here yeah
versus if it's private then that's when
corruption exactly or of all sorts it's
just it's hard to imagine that you could
trust something if you don't know where
it's coming from exactly okay so and
then I can choose to have this be on
like a decentralized distributed ledger
of public voting yeah we're already yeah
we're already doing that it's kind of
beta testing right now but we publish a
ledger of all the votes and it can be
mirrored very easily yeah and you can
see the complete history and so just to
just to yeah get back to this again the
point is that in what I believe to be a
healthier democracy for the 21st century
you actually know your representative
these aren't these like far away ideas
of these like politicians you heard
about from the TV or from like a
30-second ad or you know you have this
very limited it they're almost like
pitch to us like products is very
limited exposure to them yeah it's a
pretty bad thing that their pitch to us
is like a product yeah well it's it's
the best they can do because they have
to convince a billion people it's the
only way to get elected yeah they've
such a limited amount of time in the
future though instead of picking between
Canada and Canada be you'll actually be
able to pick your friend or your family
member or your professor or someone you
really admire and you chose yourself you
don't need anyone elses permission you
get to be represented by the people you
trust great great and then on a on a on
a final like counts level like how do we
ensure that there that that the final
seis from in this liquid democracy
style of voting are being non corrupted
towards the final decisions on
legislature what sort of corruption
do you have specifically maybe like just
making sure that when we're trying to
say that like Ashley who already has
like a good amount of people that trust
her that the way that she's voting in is
not being corrupted like what is our
stuff tribes yeah and what is their
security that that like how does how is
actually submitting that last mile to
the yeah that that's not being
manipulated like you know is this
happening computationally how is this
occurring yeah so so we built the system
called proof of vote and so this gets
into the the ledger that we're talking
about the public ledger and so basically
anytime a vote gets entered so we so we
built the interface to take all the
votes and it's open source and people
can build other interfaces we want these
to be like democracy browsers sort of
but when you cast the vote it gets
entered into this official ledger of all
the votes where you have the proof of
all the votes and so you if it's public
you can just see your name in there and
if it's private then we want to provide
basically a vote ID so it's a unique
code like six eight three to five ad and
you get a you get a receipt when you
cast your vote and so you can look up
and see there's my vote and anyone can
tabulate all of us so it's a it's a
transparent this is technical terms is
referred to as end-to-end vote
tabulation both verification and
verification yeah because you you know I
cast my vote and I can see my vote in
the final yeah I know yeah okay cool
yeah okay and there are ways that it can
be even stronger in the future with like
cryptographically signed messages or a
little ways away from that youth in
general or attitude is make something
easy for people to start using
and always be open and transparent about
the ways in which we want to strengthen
things technologically so we right now
we don't have cryptographically signed
votes but we'd like to get to that in
the future yeah and then you'd be able
to say you could be able to verify the
your vote got entered correctly and sign
that message we'd be able to say okay
90% of people have verified and all I
could happen automated as well so that's
a that's a fascinating subject yeah
that's that's heading us into the future
as well
let's hit on there were some of them
some of the things that you guys
actually passed as well so a B 1505 and
I'm for local control and Senate bill
126 for conflict of interest should we
show the the page where it showed kind
of like how you guys put that together
that that was pretty interesting for me
well totally you show me that yeah so
this is all at charter law reform calm
reformed yeah great so we've been
talking about today to up till now is
the long term vision for what 21st
century democracy can look like thinking
about you know 30 years from now what
sort of democracy would be better for us
to live in mm-hmm and it's a fascinating
conversation for people that are
interested in this the hope the tricky
part is okay that's that's the long-term
vision how do we get from where we are
today
yeah to there so what we've been doing
is we've been working with advocacy
organizations on the ground right now
who want to pass a specific piece of
legislation and so that's what this is
an example of so this is working with
these group of retired teachers
educators here in California try to
change the California state law around
what are called charter schools charter
schools are privately run schools that
receive public funding usually
nonprofits some people confuse that but
they're almost always nonprofits
and there are some cases where they work
really well but there are other cases
where they don't work really well and
there's
we're talking a huge amount of taxpayer
money you're in my money that goes to
them and sometimes they can end up
harming a lot of other students kids
kids
so this group of teachers they
understood the current law it's called
the 1992 California charter law charter
act charter school Act yes and
understand the current law they had very
specific ideas about the ways we want to
tweak the existing law to help solve
this problem that the state is facing
the current educational system is facing
so they had these five particular
legislative policy ideas and one of them
has already been passed signed into law
signed by the governor that was known as
SB 126 Senate bill 126 and that provides
legal restrictions around conflicts of
interests so apply to charter school
board members the same prohibition of
conflict of interest as applied to
public school boards exactly so the
charter schools are typically nonprofits
but they're receiving a huge amount of
taxpayer money here am i public funding
hundreds of billions of dollars on the
charter school board and I also own the
company that sells desks I exactly yeah
I can't just buy exactly the desks or my
face Arsenal company yeah yeah yeah
things like that non-controversial too
controversial that's why it got passed
so quickly
not exactly virtual it just needed to be
that code update how do you get it as
fast as possible well if you go to
charter charter law firm then you can
easily endorse parts of this yourself
and give people the representatives
moving in the direction that you want
exactly
so 2,100 people have done that so all
across California people have been
weighing in and saying yes we need this
and there
adding in personal comments and personal
stories and so on and so forth and every
time someone adds in we automatically
send their message along to their
particular state Reps and we can verify
are these actual registered voters
because on the internet there's a lot of
fraud going on so we've done a lot of
work making it as easy as possible and
also making it as trustworthy as
possible so we want to confirm that
these are real people and get their
messages to their specific legislators
and then this is this is what we call a
liquid initiative it's a liquid
initiative yeah it's an initiative that
started on the liquid US platform and so
there have been you know dozen different
initiatives that we've been starting and
we always want to work with existing
group that that knows here's the problem
here's what the legislative solution
looks like yeah and we can help set that
up and we're doing in all different
states in all different cities all
across the country yeah like you said
just more and more of these liquid
initiatives all different states
yeah across the country that's fantastic
and then having people actually like you
said every single time they endorse make
a comment send that off make the push
has happened so right so right now what
what people say is you call your call
your representative call your member of
Congress call your your state
representative state senator and is what
people think is the best way to make an
impact on policy and it comes from a
good place the problem that I personally
always have when I do it is that I call
in I usually a voicemail or something or
you know maybe I get an answer and it's
like then what happens it kind of goes
in this black hole nobody ever hears
anything from it so what we are doing
that's really distinct is that this
these citizen positions are totally
public and people when when you call in
other people recognize and can see X
number of people are in favor of this
and why and our people are against it
and so what we're building towards is to
actually create scorecards for every
representative
mm-hmm so in the same way right now
politicians will get these grades from
representatives like they'll get an A
grade or an F grade from the NRA we're
working towards being able to offer
liquid scorecards for every elected
representative that very simply instead
of saying does your voting record match
with the NRA board wants it's just your
voting record match what your verified
constituents how they want you to vote
and so that's called liquid scorecards
and that's one of the benefits of
weighing in this way on top of just
being easier and more verified we're
trying to create more accountability
yeah great way to create more
accountability and so you could actually
look up and say okay for this
representative how good of a job are
they doing actually listen their
constituents on education issues versus
science issues versus foreign policy
issues versus so on and so forth yeah
even broken down by category as well
let's um some of the next assets that we
have let's go to the next one okay so
this is the selecting proxy by issue
area so let's hit that one
yeah we want to hit the next asset
alright there it is you know actually
this one yeah sure so I think you know
one of the things that really appeals to
me about the idea of liquid democracy is
that it's very humble I think in a
perfect world all of our representatives
would be experts on everything they
would know everything about science and
economics and foreign policy but that's
just not the reality of how the world
works
we all specialize in different things
Albert Einstein was great at physics I
don't know how much he knew about
healthcare Nancy Pelosi has been working
in government for decades and decades
and she knows a good amount about each
issue but it's hard to call her you know
a leading expert on all of them you know
there's no perfect person out there and
so there's you know we have within a
liquid democratic system this idea of
proxying where if you don't have the
time or the expertise to weigh in on a
particular issue you can delegate your
vote to somewhere else someone else but
another thing that can be layered on top
of that is not just choosing one proxy
for everything but having an itch you
know different proxies for different
issues
oh yeah and so you could choose you know
Neil deGrasse Tyson as your science
delegate meaning any time a bill comes
up in front of Congress that has to do
with you know a scientific topic like
NASA for example you could vote on it
yourself and if you don't Neil deGrasse
Tyson votes in it for you and the same
thing can be true you know on a
issue-by-issue basis and so I think this
is a really really powerful idea because
you know not only do we want our
representatives to be the people that we
trust the most we need them to be pretty
smart because this stuff is really
complicated we want them to be experts
we want them to be really knowledgeable
in their field you know the Affordable
Care Act was something like 2,000 pages
I don't have time to read it
and even if I did I don't know how well
I would understand all the details there
because I don't have a background in
health care law my mom is a health care
lawyer she really knows that stuff and
not only that but she has like dozens of
friends who are you know who are even
greater experts in that area than she is
and so I think this is the the
issue-by-issue proxying feature is one
of the things that really attracted me
to liquid democracy because it
feels like we'll get such better such
more set you know so much more informed
outcomes than we're getting now yeah Wow
by even proxy by issue area so if I'm
already well versed in the specific
issue area I can continuously be voting
my in my own stake there but for ones
that I don't understand all this proxy
off to the specific leaders and those
fields and it allows you to focus as
well you know you're gonna be really
knowledgeable about some topics but not
about other ones you can I do a better
job on the ones that you are interested
in because you know that the other ones
are being taken care of by people you
trust just like in our private and our
private economy you know if different
people specialize as tailors as
carpenters making furniture as engineers
making electronics it'd be crazy to
imagine every last person I do every
last thing themselves yeah and so
government is the tool we solve
collective problems different people are
gonna have different areas of interests
and areas of expertise to how we deal
with different collective problems we
face you know we'll set and then on the
on the future we have the next asset
yeah that's so yeah this gets into a
different idea of the of how we make
liquid democracy reality so we talked a
second ago about the liquid scorecards
there's this other idea and this is this
is really the thing that captured my
imagination early on was okay so we're
talking about delegate of democracy what
better democracy could look like the the
intuitive response is good luck you know
gonna pass a constitutional amendment
good luck no chance for obvious reasons
that that's right
but the difference is the idea is
running these new people for office and
working with existing people in office
who say I want to test this out just for
this one single seat just for this one
single elected position and so rather
than trying to pursue a constitutional
amendment I'm just gonna run for this
office and you can vote a liquid
representative system in just for this
one position and so that's what this
liquid Canada today so this is a mock-up
a little to frame comic
the Speaker of the House kind of looks
like Nancy Pelosi asking different
representatives how do you vote and this
representative is the liquid candidate
so they pull out their phone and write
on their phone this is intentionally
provocative they push an announce vote
button and they hold their phone up to
the microphone and their phone says the
people of District five vote YES so all
they are is this button pusher they got
elected simply to actually represent the
will of their constituents the person is
superfluous
yeah and that's this is an extreme this
is a character in real life they're
gonna be in the room they have a huge
role to play and and debate and
communicating what's happening okay so
and so forth but the final vote is yes
tallied electronically by the people and
then yeah yeah so this is a liquid
candidate I'm just gonna say so
so David could talk more about this
because he actually ran for office but
each liquid candidate can have their own
sort of policy about how they're gonna
use feedback on the app to make
decisions and so some people can say I'm
always going to vote exactly in
accordance with what the app tells me
100% of the time and then other people
could say you know I'll use the app as a
really useful feedback mechanism but at
the end of the day I'm gonna use my own
judgment kind of to make the final
decision and then other people can say
you know if a certain threshold a
certain percentage of my constituency
votes then I'll make the decision like
3% or 5% or whatever you they don't make
decisions according with the app but you
know it's a it's a flexible concept for
sure yeah but it's really powerful
because it gives us a way to implement
liquid democracy in America today
without having to change any laws or
pass it without you need to ask the
current people in power Haley
volunteered to give up your power and
say we just run for office yeah yeah as
liquid candidates yeah and all the
nuance that you just broke down yeah and
so it's also much safer because there's
you know this is a powerful idea but
it's a relatively new idea and there's a
lot of details
it's still need to be ironed out and
things that need to evolve and so the
benefit of doing it on this seat by seat
approach is that the issues that we will
face are isolated just to that seat at a
time rather than trying to say okay
yesterday the whole system was one way
tomorrow we're gonna change it all
overnight yeah I mean that's that's
incredibly disruptive that's not wise or
smart or something like that and the
next accid actually shows the the
Digital democracy candidates yeah yeah
so there have been nearly a dozen people
who have run in past elections so this
goes back to 2014 yeah Here I am
who have run for a legislative position
somewhere in the US some at the national
level so I'm at the local level some of
the state level of all different parties
so that's an interesting question are
they running in the major parties are
they running a third party or they run
independent and then what the specifics
of their pledge was control basically
means they they're promising that they
will do every vote in a hundred percent
of coordinates whereas engaged or you've
used the word empowered means don't use
it as advisory but they're not
necessarily committing okay so look who
controlled is the nuance where all of
the liquid democracy that's voted the
constituency you vote in that exact
direction to engaged means that you'll
consider what that is okay yeah yeah the
requirement the weed that we really like
people direct controlled is when they
directly control it backed versus liquid
part means are you accepting proxy bets
is it just direct democracy so the
number of people especially early on
have said I'm gonna run for office I'm
gonna give everyone an app that tells me
how to vote and and it's just one person
one vote
there's no proxy involved okay got it
yeah so it's just direct democracy and
liquid includes the prom it clearly
includes a broad includes representation
I think that's really important
otherwise it's really difficult for
people the thing is that it's it's hard
to imagine someone that says they'll be
direct
usually someone that's into direct would
also like to support liquid they just
don't have the technology to make it
possible so that's part of our what we
see our role is making it free and easy
and trustworthy and so and I should be
more common but we but when we publish
the proof of votes you can see on every
vote whether it's a direct vote or a
proxy vote so again like I was saying
every candidate and every elected
official has their the right to say I'm
only an accept direct votes if they want
or proxy vote mm-hmm and that's sort of
a good thing because it allows us to
kind of a b test a lot of different
approaches to what a what do people
respond to best so a lot of people
thought it was really important when i
was running that i have like a break
glass in case of emergency clause hmm
where if i would i'd be controlled by
everything but if for some reason you
know the imagine the worst possible vote
you can think of i would be able to go
against it okay but then I'd have to
stand immediately up for a recall that
sure sure so if I took the the break
glass if I took the emergency you vote
my own way then everyone in my district
would then be asked hey do you agree
with David's explanation for why I did
this or would you like him to resign
damn this is a lot of code like you know
if you do this emergency break glass
function and then they get to know
immediately on if they want to keep you
or not like that's good stuff the this
is how to use computer science for
democracy yeah and now I was specific to
me other people might not want that
yeah then so you can make your own
clauses see which causes are popular
yeah people can pick them up add them
yeah this is great stuff so right now
there have been you know twelve odd
people or whatever this number yeah well
now there's Agatha right so these are
just a few that made it onto the ballot
there's a whole nother slide of there's
a lot of people that have announced
their intention to do it but didn't make
it onto the ballot number that's the
last slide I think right this is about
article people talking about liquid
virus e all around the world
so they've been paper academic papers
this was a PhD thesis that really ironed
out the original mechanisms there in
essays there have been things that went
on the front page of Reddit with 40,000
up votes other academic papers and all
different newspapers around the world so
it's a it's a growing as a growing area
of interest yeah my favorite one is the
Google votes they used actually at
Google's campus they used a liquid
democratic voting structure internally
to make a lot of interesting decisions
you know from trivial things like how
should what meals should we have in the
cafeteria so you could vote on what
meals you wanted or you could proxy to
someone else it's just yeah the things
like how should we spend the charity
budget which is very very cool text test
case and actually there's someone named
Sergey pitov and my cousin who's working
there right right now who's working on
sort of building out that system further
at Google and so this kind of technology
has a lot of interesting applications
not just for government but also in
private organizations or unions or
political parties as well so it's pretty
versatile it's great yeah yeah because
these are some of these companies of a
hundred thousand yeah they're like as
big as government so that's great so
yeah liquid democracy apply to all you
know corporations yeah yeah it's really
just thinking what
what does healthier democracy look like
for the 21st century for the Information
Age what we have right now is Industrial
Age democracy what is Information Age
democracy what is the information age
democracy yeah the exponential
technology exactly a billion humans on
the planet democracy yeah yeah this has
been very interesting and I feel as
though we're you know we're totally
headed in this direction it's just like
getting the short term that you guys are
building to get you to get us to the
long term where we see it happening it's
just it's the critical stepping stones
that have to happen to get us there and
even just the conversation about liquid
democracy you know having others share
with their friends their families
co-workers people online
there's no critical like whoa liquid
democracy totally democracy 3.0 look at
the history where we're at now the stuff
yeah yeah so most people are not aware
of this I mean have you especially be
walking on the street nobody will have
heard of the term when you ask people in
a room you know you'll typically get
like 1% or something like that but it is
growing I mean I've had a firsthand
exposure to it just over the last few
years more and more people are reaching
out people are doing this all over the
world so just yesterday I'd people
starting a similar group in Romania
reach out and there's groups in Canada
and France and Germany and India and
Australia and all over the world
constantly reaching out for liquid
democracy in there Wow the thing is that
there's a certain inevitability to it
though there's a mathematical
inevitability to it because if you think
the person that gets elected they get
elected by the majority unless what
they're their voting record on every
single issue already matches what the
majority of people want then no matter
what the liquid candidate must be making
more people happier on more issues it's
just it's just mathematically how could
one person out of a million do a better
job than the combined efforts of all
those people yeah yeah the challenge of
course is awarenesses do all the people
know about it see as an option and so
simple how frictionless is it exactly
and so that is really plays into the
need for the liquid candidates so every
time a person runs for office the press
loves to write about that so I got a
bunch of press about me other people
have written so one of my friends ran
for for a Senate seat he estimated that
hundreds of thousands of new people
learned about liquid democracy just
because he ran even though he didn't he
don't win he didn't make it on the
ballot and so the point is that Nathan I
was gonna say yeah and I should mention
he's uh where's what state is in Indiana
yeah and so a lot of people have this
assumption that oh this is kind of like
a San Francisco Silicon Valley tech
thing no one in Indiana would want to
use this but he had a lot of really
positive feedback from people out there
and so liquid democracy is a nonpartisan
idea it's something that appeals to
people both on the left or the right of
the spectrum or people who don't know
where they might fall on the
sort of simple dichotomy yeah yeah it's
just democracy it's healthier for
everyone and picked up by India
Australia Germany France all these are
like oh yeah that's right yeah huge a
couple couple quick questions I'm on the
way out that we like to ask our guests
this is just it's super it's just such a
good episode
let's hit on what do you guys think
where do you guys think we come from pre
birth and where do you guys think we go
post-death caught me by surprise whoa
where do we come from pre birth you go
first no good try yeah you come from the
earth come for our parents yeah where do
you think we go post death hopefully
people will remember us and share
stories about us I'll let you know when
I get there if I can't do that do you
guys think we're alone in the cosmos
probably not it's too big
are humans the only is there other life
on other planets besides Earth is that
the question
take it where you'd like I mean I don't
think we're alone on earth so as a
starting place there's lots and lots of
life-forms on earth growing numbers
sometimes okay yeah I don't know I hope
so
I hope there's more life out there Ivan
do you think we're dissimulation minded
[Music]
but the one where you would donate
unused computing power yeah yeah yeah
that was fun yeah do you guys think were
dissimulation I think it's a none
falsifiable question I don't know how
you what's the how do you measure how do
you deny it whether we are aren't okay
let's say we're in a simulation and what
created the simulation is there
simulation with no stimulation I don't
know I don't find it I don't know where
to go with the answer whether we
we are if we can get if we can escape
out of it that would be really
interesting but I don't spend a ton of
time think about it sure I love video
games I would love to see technology
progress to the point where we could
create trillions and trillions of world
that are worlds that are as or more
complex than the world that we currently
exist in you haven't got there and so
until we get to that point I remain
skeptical about the idea that we live in
a simulation but it's a powerful
argument it's definitely something that
I think about from time to time as a
gamer yeah yeah absolutely
totally all right and then last question
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in the world
the ocean stole my answer I spent a lot
of set over Ocean Beach mmm can I
combine those yeah there you go I grew
up in Half Moon Bay for most of my life
so just near San Francisco which is a
beach town that's so I spent a lot of a
lot of time out on the bluff just
enjoying the beautiful scenery yeah yeah
holy cow what a great episode of liquid
democracy this has been you guys thank
you so much for coming on yeah yeah that
was so enriching there's your work your
work is you know it's already available
for people to dive deep into which is
great already being queried from around
the world and implemented into systems
around the world it's very exciting
thank you everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below in
the episode out the links also liquid
dot us the youtube profile david's
profile the candidates profile twitter
as well check out those links share more
conversations with your friends your
co-workers people online your family
about liquid democracy and about the
future of the rethinking 21st century
democratic representation huge shout out
to ron Vargas for producing and
directing Thank You Ronnie and go and
build the future everyone manifest your
dreams into the world thank you so much
for tuning in